[Music]
I'm like Manchester - is huge
we missed Justin Bieber's voice that's
his cameo in little Dickies new earth
music video and he's not the only celeb
lending a voice to the animated vid
which aims to spread awareness about
protecting our well yep Ariana Grande
shows up as zebra and how cute does
Halsey look as a lion cub we're also
borderline obsessed with Shawn Mendes as
a pair of rhinos with a sex drive and
Miley Cyrus would sing this lyric year's
Katy Perry
Kevin Hart played Kanye West and the
best part Leonardo DiCaprio played
himself on the Titanic that guy knows
more about the earth and how we get it
up than anybody like if aliens did come
we should definitely send Leo as our guy
this might be my favorite song ever some
of the other celebs begot Zac Brown
Brendon Urie Hailee Steinfeld Snoop Dogg
and Ed Sheeran but wait there's more
celebs like Meghan Trainor John Legend
bad bunny and even the Backstreet Boys
lent their voices to the chorus of the
song
proceeds from the tune will go to
charity and little Dickey swung by The
Ellen Show to share more about why he'd
put this all together we have 12 years
to completely change the way we do so
many things on earth where the damage is
irreversible yep and like within our
lifetime well within our lifetime like
crazy things are gonna happen floods
food shortages bad air yeah millions of
people reload it's like critic dislike
very soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]